das sind so strandsand also ich kann mir
vorstellen dass es hier zigaretten
oh das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt jetzt eine
tüte mit es sieht aus wie schmuck
jeden tag gehen in deutschland 2348
koffer verloren
diese zahle ich mir jetzt nur ausgedacht
aber es ging wirklich einige koffer
verloren wer kennt es nicht man klicken
urlaub und ist aber auch erst dann
wirklich im urlaub angekommen wenn man
seinen eigenen koffer vom kofferband
abholt und da dann halt auch wirklich da
ist jetzt hat es gerade an der tür
geklingelt scheiße natürlich sehr
schlecht für die leute dessen koffer
abhanden kommt aber umso besser für mich
in deutschland gibt es ab und zu koffer
optionen in denen einige dieser koffer
versteigert werden
also ich musste ja letztens war einer
dieser koffer auktionen in köln und ich
hab mir gedacht ich war wirklich vorher
noch nie bei einer auktion das heißt für
die leute die mit dem wort es nichts
anfangen können keine ahnung ob es
überhaupt irgendwann gibt auf jeden fall
werden dinge versteigert es wird gesagt
ja als nächstes wird dieser imac
versteigert dann geht es los mit 1000
euro wer bietet mehr und der am ende am
meisten bereit ist zu geben bekommt das
ding ich fand das irgendwie sehr
interessant ich hatte es am flughafen in
köln gesehen dass es das halt gibt ihr
könnt es auch gern mal googeln das ist
glaube ich von eur wings oder so habe
ich gerade aber glaube ich auch schon
eingeblendet und das war sogar ähnlich
wie das was man aus dem fernsehen kennt
das läuft glaube ich oft kommt aus
amerika da gibt es also zwei typen die
so alte garagen ersteigern und alles was
drin ist ist im preis enthalten
ich wollte jetzt aber auch nicht 500
euro für so einen blöden koffer ausgeben
das höchste gebot für irgendeinen koffer
waren über 800 euro da wo ich war und
ich habe einen hersteller für 90 euro
ich habe ihn mitgenommen zu meinen
eltern bin wirklich gespannt ich muss
auch ehrlich sagen ich habe schon mal so
leicht von oben reingekommen sind jetzt
nicht wirklich besonders aus aber
trotzdem stelle ich mir das ganze
ziemlich interessant war auch für euch
als zuschauer und für mich eigentlich am
meisten ich habe jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon ewig gelabert ich hole mal kurz
den kopf ganz wichtig was ich eben noch
vergessen habe zu erzählen und zwar
damit ihr das prinzip dahinter versteht
also ist es nicht so dass man irgendwo
einen koffer findet und der dann sofort
zu dieser auktion gegeben wird da kommt
natürlich auch nicht jeder koffer hin
und ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau wie
das dann abläuft dass eine
fluggesellschaft sagt okay wir haben
jetzt hier so und so viele koffer
gefunden
davon könnt ihr diese koffer haben ob
die dann da abgekauft werden oder sonst
was keinen plan dann hängt natürlich
auch immer der zoll mit zwischen und in
seinem koffer sind natürlich auch
manchmal sachen die dann nicht darin
gefunden werden nachdem er halt
versteigert wird also immer bevor seine
koffer zu einer auktion kommt guckt halt
der zoll reihen also da hat vor dann
schon jemand rein guckt und wenn dann
irgendwas persönliches gefunden wird
natürlich noch versucht den besitzer zu
ermitteln wenn das aber nicht so ist
werden auch sachen wie irgendwie größere
bargeldbeträge ich glaube da kann man
gar kein geld und finden keinen plan
oder man hängt wegen waffen- drogen-
keine ahnung das wird alles vom zoll zur
seite genommen und dann wird der koffer
so abgegeben oder auch meinetwegen wenn
irgendwelche lebensmittel verdorben sind
oder verdorben können werden die auch
rausgenommen
das heißt wir können nur sachen drin
sein wie kleidung elektrogeräte keine
ahnung irgendwelche accessoires und so
weiter so hier haben wir den koffer ist
ein handgepäcks koffer ist auch wichtig
nicht schwer ich würde sagen maximal
vier piloten wobei man auch dazusagen
muss dass einem schon ganz okay aber ich
würd sagen den koffer kann man auf jeden
fall auch noch nutzen ist so schon ein
bisschen abgewandt naja also
ich will mal kurz meinem handy so den
ersten blick rein ja leute so sieht da
von oben aus ist jetzt nicht wirklich
voll also geht locker zu ja also das ist
der erste blick ich schätze mal das war
dann so einen wochenendtrip oder so ich
würde auch mal direkt tippen auf
weiblich also falls irgendwelche seinen
koffer wiedererkennt wobei man auch gar
nicht sagen kann ob das überhaupt von
einer deutschen touristin es hier ist
auch kein name oder so dran sonst wäre
er ja logischerweise zurückgeschickt war
oder der besitzer war versucht worden zu
ermitteln sagt man das so natürlich ist
es auch ein bisschen eklig finde ich
wenn ich da jetzt einfach darin
herumwühlen würde deswegen habe ich
jetzt diesen stopp ich fange einfach
stumpf von oben an wir haben hier als
erstes kompagnon anfassen richter auf
jeden fall auch nach irgendwas als ich
bin mir eigentlich zu 100 prozent sicher
dass es von einer frau ein tuch für den
hals habe ich schon immer gesucht und
das gleiche haben wir auch noch mal also
hier noch ein pinkes tuch von weiß ich
dass das gefällt mir eigentlich sogar
natürlich jetzt nicht für mich selber
aber so generell für frauen warum nicht
wisst ihr unbequem mir das auch so
schwer irgendwie eine passende kamera
position zu finden dass man den koffer
einigermaßen drauf hat wobei ich den ja
gar nicht sehen könnt und mich halt auch
okay wir machen einfach mal mit dieser
box wetter hier drin ist einfach ja gut
die seite ist zwar frisch aber an seife
werden bitte seine eigene seife mit oder
dann auch noch so eine seite gut im
flieger davon in sachen bis 150
milliliter mitnehmen also kann ich sogar
verstehen dass es so eine seife ist ich
schließe jetzt auch eher mal so auf
ältere dame jetzt habe ich wenigstens
mal wieder seife als nächstes haben wir
hier einen gürtel mit einem hart dran
jetzt rutscht mir meine hose nicht mehr
runter dass hier auch unglaublich genial
ein hut muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
auf setzen ist also ein ganz typischer
der strand tot
für personen des mittleren alters oder
irgendwelche 25-jährigen besoffenen
mallorca touristen ja mal sowas auch oft
auf auch ein buch ok als nächstes haben
wir hier ein buch zwei frauen ein altes
haus und eine honda dörte alle leute die
im letzten jahr kein einziges buch
gelesen haben geben jetzt mal daumen
oben dann kann ich mir das video nämlich
auch selber leiten und als nächstes
haben wir hier tue das sind so
strandsand also ich kann mir vorstellen
dass es hier zigaretten
oh das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht
leute zigaretten sind hier drin auf
deutsch schraubten verursacht
herzanfälle deswegen gehe ich jetzt mal
von das buch ja auch auf deutsch bin
nicht dumm es ist auf jeden fall in
deutschland gut wenn er jetzt von eur
wings ist die fliegen auch meistens in
deutschland dann kann man es verstehen
wieso man zigaretten als vor dem koffer
hat und nicht in der handtasche gut
hier hatten wir die schuhe ich weiß
natürlich auch gar nicht wie lange der
koffer da jetzt schon lag oder wie lange
er schon vermisst wird auf jeden fall
haben wir hier schuhe von tamaris kenne
ich mich überhaupt nicht mit aus könnt
ihr gern mal in die kommentare schreiben
ob man die noch verkaufen kann ich denke
er nicht und hier der zweite also wenn
ich mir das jetzt so angucke weil sie
nicht maximal 25 euro wert bis jetzt
machen wir weiter mit dieser dose die
aber leer ist weil sie nicht vielleicht
war das für die andere seite bestimmt
oder sie wollte sich noch extra sei weil
dort nach kaufen die sie hier rein tut
wir haben hier noch einen waschlappen
und wir haben noch einen waschlappen und
mir ist gerade mal aufgefallen was ja
auch sehr wichtig ist zu sagen der kopf
heißt ja auf jeden fall für den hinflug
gedacht weil er nichts benutztes oder so
das sieht alles ja frisch aus auf die
wahlschlappe mir überhaupt nicht benutzt
als nächstes haben wir hier noch
sonnencreme vielleicht links für ein
wochenende in die sonne gute sonnencreme
kann man auch in deutschland gebrauchen
wenn es warm ist aber wahrscheinlich
ging es in die sonne für ein wochenende
dann ist der koffer vermutlich auch gar
nicht erst mitgeflogen sondern sie hat
ihn anscheinend direkt in deutschland
vergessen oder was auch immer als
nächstes haben wir hier eine frau eine
frauen sporthose oder so zahnbürsten
das hier ist irgendwann creme wir haben
wir weiterreden creme eine sonnenbrille
gut leute eine sonnenbrille gibt keine
marke dran
wie kann ich mein wegen mal aufsetzen
das ist mir eigentlich ganz okay die ist
sogar mit stärke das heißt leichte
sehschwäche mir wird da irgendwie mal
schwindelig wenn ich sowas auf habt also
kann ich eigentlich nichts mit anfangen
wenn jetzt irgendwas von den sachen als
wertvoller kennen dann schreibt es auf
jeden fall gerne in die kommentare hier
haben wir socken
dann haben wir
auch ein paar socken auch beides frisch
auch noch eine unterhose das gut gehört
auch dazu und hier haben wir ein irrtum
genial auch okay jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ich hier ist eine tüte mit es
sieht aus wie schmuck ich habe absolut
keine ahnung davon
jetzt kommt ihr ins spiel wenn ihr euch
mit schmuck auskennt wir haben hier gut
das weiß jetzt nicht es blitzt hat auf
jeden fall aber ein stein ist auch schon
abgefallen
schaut euch das mal gerne an hier ich
will jetzt erst mal nicht als wertvoll
einstufen
aber man weiß ja nicht schreibt gerne in
die kommentare das legt man hier zur
seite
dann haben wir hier noch mehr schmuck
das sind so reif dass ich nicht mal
durch mir das ist zum umhängen sondern
da warst also das hier ist wirklich
überhaupt nicht mein geschmack da
immerhin geste so nicht verloren und wir
haben noch ein armband und zwar dieses
hier mit so einer kugel dran
ich habe keine ahnung vielleicht kommt
man insgesamt mit diesem schmuck auf 50
euro vielleicht aber auch nicht dass
hier ist lippenstift oder lippenstift ok
und dass sie könnte noch die marke ist
glaube ich etwas teurer
marc cain und so eine bluse also der
koffer gehört auf jeden fall einer frau
man hier haben wir noch irgendwas ja von
ganz unten haben wir noch ein handtuch
und eine tüte
ja man muss ich ehrlich sagen das war's
eigentlich schon ich habe natürlich
gehofft dass irgendwas extrem cooles
drin ist ich bin euch mal kurz den
schmuck doch ein vielleicht kann man
damit ja was anfangen also hier haben
wir noch einmal dieses armband
hier haben wir dann so eine kette für
den hals also halskette mit zum ding
hier unten dran und hier haben wir noch
diese kuhglocke damit man auch immer
weiß was ich die person auf könnte ich
auch hier mit nun drücken so kühr kann
ich das auch einer umhängen vielleicht
erkennt ja auch wirklich jemand seinen
koffer hier wieder kann ja sein es war
es leider kein iphone oder so drin hätte
ich natürlich selber rein tun können und
es dann den titel schreiben aber der
kopf war wirklich nicht mehr als 90 euro
wer trotzdem bin ich mal gespannt wie
das bei euch ankommt lasst mir gerne
daumen nach oben da wenn ihr sagt alex
besuch bitte auch mal an
aktion wo es noch mehr opfer gibt und
schlagt ihr noch einmal zu weil ich
finde das wirklich sehr interessant vor
allem so eine aktion format wie ich das
im fernsehen gesehen hat gibt es auf
youtube noch gar nicht so ganz und ja
das war's mit dem video wir sehen uns
heute ein